good evening everybody welcome to
tonight's presentation for a 70
I'll start by reading out the emergency
evacuation announcement in the event of
a fire or other emergency please execute
in a normal manner to the assembly point
which is located in the market car park
the fire exit in this room is indicated
by green fire exit sign please do not
delay the evacuation I'll talk to you
any problems please do not use the lift
the premises must not be reentered until
the Fire Brigades have given you all
clear please note it is against the law
to smoke on these premises please also
note that this meeting will be of
members apologies for absence
we have apologies from the council in
this story and counselors is Lumley
substitute members we have counselor
mrs. voice or or counselor mr. point
normally members attending counselor
Smith and counselor sparing item 4 which
is the minister to meeting held in
United January members happy to sign any
declarations of interest counselor mr.
drug item 6 mr. chairman as a member of
Riley town council in particular
chairman of the crowd your toilets of
meeting or working good way
with Stanley
thank you what's a six-pack mr. Lamba
item six mr. lamborne I don't think he's
here oh my my eyes I need my optician
said I would suffer some problems we get
started and I need to say that as a
leader abroad for distant residents that
I have agreed that mr. lamborne will be
a prospective candidate for the
elections discuss the item with the
monitoring officer the deputy monitoring
officer at the time who agreed that I
should make this interesting duration
but it has no further reports the
following issues were considering
tonight because their procedural thank
you
I think you've got the note that you
need to make a statement tonight
well I some of the points that we this
is a button quotes from emails that I've
made and they made to me I just like to
emphasize a few of the points there but
you you will need to go through each one
of those in detail but my first stone
point I wish to make was that they could
pass up if we give you five at least you
think they'll be enough time Peter
Morgan thank you first of the despite
promises or whatever from officers that
the item will be debates it didn't
actual debate one of the principal
questions in the petition was that there
will be a presentation of the full costs
of the refit the estimated constant
and for the toilets so that members
would have been able to see when the
cost of refurbishment was less than or
more than the cost of building when the
toilet
unfortunately the meeting was railroaded
by the leader in the portfolio holder
and a motion put by counsel standing was
totally ignored and I found that
particularly incorrect at the council
meeting I found in the when the petition
was proposed i found the officer were no
help they were able to tell me what I
couldn't say but they didn't try and
help me in framing the petition in a way
that I wanted in that the principal the
part of the petition was as I say to
present costs so that the council would
be able to see whether it was a
justified in doing what with what they
did I found it
infuriating that the Constitution was
able to be used to exclude my position
from being put before this committee and
mr. hull cotton mask to justify its
situation but the Constitution was then
turned on his head
previously in that the petition that was
originally proposed by Councilman oopall
had been refused for no constitutional
reason whatsoever so for me they were
the officers were quoting the
Constitution but for the previous
attempts to raise this
petition was refused for no
constitutional reason whatsoever and
thirdly on the procedure of the actual
petition the officers are people
yourself pointed out cancer certain that
they there were duplicates in then the
offices of mrs. totally miss Martha
point or the subsequent complaint about
the amount of testing they must have
done to the systems it is the end-users
with who is responsible to sign up not
the software provider clearly I relied
upon the systems as would anyone it must
be embarrassing to the council to have
you yourself counselor than to highlight
these problems when they didn't find
them themselves maybe there is an
endemic problem with the idea RDC all
the system problems they had seemed to
lead to this conclusion
[Music]
the questions that you raised in your
email that you did receive response on
unsatisfied be very unsatisfied with the
the fact that the masa was dealt with in
council rather than being dealt with
over review and also that the the
officers would like to justify made the
decision I've looked at the business
case that met Marcus Holt unless it had
reduced the which was the basis of the
decision and it doesn't include the
costs in the detailed manner during the
debate all that was said would it would
cost a lot of money it would cost a lot
of money and nobody ever said what the
think there was soem be satisfied and
dissatisfied with their answers on the
testing and dissatisfied with the
support that officers gives neighbors
are publicly seen to they don't seem to
want to have a pass but where they look
they're prepared to help their political
masters
John Mostow would you like to respond at
the moment would you are you able to
watch responds within the comments
though mr. land organised German are you
know the indicated Appendix B starting
on page six point eleven does does
provide responses their responsibilities
offices with each year I think the only
addition there's been raised and I
understand it is that the full costing
cohesion although I need to go back to
the prayer of the petition
I think if counsel had agreed the
petition then full costs would have
would have come forward that's the only
yeah I'm a bit additional to nothing to
add chairman thank you I must admit I'm
a bit concerned I wasn't at the council
meeting it this was heard but I have
here I can say that that they would like
to the current we're pretty costed
proposals be presented to the crown here
quotes to be refurbished to maintain
resuming that was almost the detail of
the petition then the council should
have carried that out and I don't know
the answer to this but there does seem
to be a lack of clarity that the other
thing that are very concerned about is
that mr. lamborne
is if I may say so technically generally
I will in a very able resident but a
petition process should be accessible to
any resident it should be easily
understandable it should be clear and we
should be able to communicate it to any
resident and it would appear that in
this situation that hasn't happened
and I'm just concerned that going
forward that perhaps tens should be some
greater clarity counselor mr. Mason well
you won't be surprised to hear I was
wasn't present either at the full
council meeting they've considered this
miss petition then I'm actually not
going to comment about that I do know
that another resident contacted me on
another British to ask me what they had
to do and I must admit I got rather
frustrated because I went to the play
you said he told me about I found I had
to enter an email address or some form
of ID and no matter what I did what he
did he didn't give access to to the
online basis and ultimately I had to put
him in touch with the offices in the
lender services to help you because I
just couldn't do it and I became aware
of the email and I don't know quite to
what this how this copy of him had a
rose but it was from the legal officer
and the legal officer sent quite a long
email somebody explaining a great deal
more about the petitions process than
ever I knew what was ever in the
Constitution and actually interestingly
referred to an active Club so I think we
I concluded from all of that but I don't
think we've got enough support for
residents who are raising petitions I
don't think is a situation where we
should just be answering questions I
think it needs to be quite proactive
because you've got a better mind these
are the things that members of the
public
they are residents who obviously taken
an interest in something I want answers
and they won't they won't understand
which Act applies and this very strange
act which I've referred something about
the construction act or something I was
very very find it very odd because it
was obviously the right thank you but
it's not one that I was and if I were
either trying to to make the petition I
I don't think from what the council
presented on its website this resident
to do afterwards and the email that I
saw from the officer explaining there
was a great deal more in the statute
than in our Constitution that we
probably haven't done enough yeah I
think sort of lockers and basic
principle we and in other areas where
the council comes into contact with the
general public we expect our offices to
be helpful and assist them you know
we've we've we really we're using
questions you know that in particular
we've regard to issues about planning
and stuff like that
the emphasis is on assisting the general
public in their applications so I think
in this area on something that can be
would seem to be quite complicated and
quite for your pratik we would expect
that around our offices to be as helpful
with residents to help them through the
process rather than leave them to get on
with their chairman yep I did originally
submitted petition and it was rejected
even though it's not in the Constitution
that I am NOT allowed to submit a
petition and I also did take advice from
the late Chris black he was a very
experienced counselor
Russians and mathematician and he too
thought I should be able to submit that
petition
I think the council's failed the
petitioner is the Lamborn because as
councillor Mason said I am cats a hook
way it's not enough guidance the
system's funky it's not clear on what
they need to on the detail of what the
petitioner needs to submit a petition
should be encouraged by the council
myself and I'd like to see it have an
overhaul Thank You mr. Austin the
problems things that of stemming from
potentially the wording that was used at
the outset of creating the petition and
it seems as a council game is kind of
ice what should used is that something
that the council exceptional
circumstances water council took that
decision to advise upon the world
chairman that max referred to on page
six point eleven the paragraphs there
three words in our view
I mean if Eve
generally speaking and we don't get a
lot of petitions and with some subject
areas like planning you can't have
petitions generally speaking if if the
yulie contact with the office asking
about petitions because the public one
necessarily know about a constitution
even and that's about to talk talking
through some sometimes we may get sent a
petition out of blue without having seen
it or been able to offer advice on it
and either occasionally the the
important thing is to keep the wording
of whoever's presented it that that's
important and maybe at you know if even
discussions and you think well it might
help you know you might suggest the the
odds the odds were but no I mean I you
want to see what what petitioner
provided actually would with a number of
other opportunities for interaction with
with with with residence so but in this
particular instance chairman 6.11 onward
sees is the is the commentary around mr.
land just apparently after submitting
the petition using the word recommended
to you did the council clearly and
inform you about the difference that was
entered to for counsel
and the review committee asked the
number of Shinobi you obtained no no
they're having rippy if they're prepared
to edit it to put these three words you
can they could have said and by the way
you need to
as the officer for this bit where you
want the presentation of the figures
okay did you receive the letter or the
acknowledgment but did you receive the
acknowledgments yes and did in that
acknowledgement it was there any mention
of it says there obviously an
acknowledgement will be sent to the
petition organised within 10 working
days of receiving a petition we let them
know what we plan to do with the
petition and when they can expect to
hear from us again in that big knowledge
money was it thanks I'm not questioning
your counsel it would be ten days from
when the council received a position yes
ever since I received an enlargement to
say we accepted you edited your wording
on that ad and and was the petitioner
available or was it sent to the
petitioner or what edited they've done
and the other thing that comes to mind
is there wasn't enough discussion at
fault cancel when after mr. lamborne had
spoken and it was put out to council
members there wasn't enough discussion
on that particular time and was abruptly
cut short by the Chairman which I
thought was a little bit you know
somewhat we listed there were councilor
who has got a view who he's in the
industry if you like of doing these sort
of things and he was cut short
straightaway I've only spent speaking
about two minutes I felt that that was
that was somewhat you know really Road
at the someone
however when along with the rest of the
council at that particular time but I
think that we've got to the council have
got to allow on items like this which
involves the public so much so much so
that we need to they need to you know
they need to have their counselor who is
representing the public it's a voice
that people thank you this is just a
small or something I think I picked up
when listening this is my understanding
was an e petition and I understand that
the application correctly what wrong was
made electronically and yet from what
I'm hearing the response was in writing
so it wasn't it wasn't so okay thank you
as the Year petition process forms part
of the Constitution of the council and
this is under review at the moment from
work to group of this committee is this
something that that working group is
going to be able to look at in detail
and making a recommendation back to this
committee for any alterations I think
that probably one suggestion and my
recommendation
I think notes that has merit mr.
chairman and certainly it would appear
to be the place but bearing in mind it's
40 ml seems that working party has met I
wouldn't like to see this item left for
14 months so perhaps we could be more
proactive and ask mr. boss topically
cooked to a draft for us of having heard
the concerns have been expressed which
would speed things up and then if the
working party isn't able to meet and
consider this in a timely fashion then
it will have to be considered that this
committee I'm just checking because I
think there is a minute yes it's the 15
oh yes it's pretty sever so 27
that's fortunate since the last meeting
I think that a decision for it to be
before council was probably done with
the right intentions thinking as there
was a similar position I have no problem
with that if they arms the Beckley
question they didn't it was probably
better for council rather than a review
and had it been good to review anyway by
duo C except job for that perhaps I
think you should have been cleaning
and where you want a bit to be presented
first I think the recommendation from
this committee should be this urgently
Constitution Welcome Party to make it
clear about the process from the
decisions that are made on how petitions
are accepted and discussed council can I
add to that the issue that I raised
written that that was it is not the only
part of our Constitution but sets out a
basis for something and yes when you
come to actually rely upon it
you told that it's in such-and-such
their act I'm sorry that you can't do
that or you can do that and although we
can't get everything in their
constitution we can't be simply company
on place whole bits of Acts because that
doesn't work I think what we need to do
is have references to those acts in the
places where it's you know been in
explaining from the act that is not the
act itself because that gives whoever's
using it the opportunity to go to the
app take advice as to you know before we
make a complete chump in themselves
which I've done in the past so in this
particular case it's a classic example
well I know there's an act verifies to
this I think it would have been helpful
for everyone to know that it was and we
could return to it if we wish to so
that's my addition that to ensure that
the constitutional Constitution task
group considers in every instance where
there is act Parliament of statute that
applies that it should be coded by the
to the Constitution so you know where
there is
thank you mr. jereth allow me to come by
yeah I'd certainly endorse what
counselor mr. Mason said but I would
like to say because of the problem that
the Constitution working but he won't
know what that's like we don't that
that's what I've asked a suggestion that
mr. BOTS don't be able to do a draft
report for us to work from it's at least
you can then give us the acts that we've
got to incorporate otherwise we're gonna
sit there and drive something but we
don't know what we're doing because we
don't know the law we really don't
taking those points into consideration
is that something you think you couldn't
do for us before the next Constitution
reaches the 15th of March do you think
you have a draft the inclusion for the
15th
27:27 and Sherman I'm sensing that the
reference to the legislation is perhaps
broader across the of the Constitution
and is the intent as well as you know
something this is that construction
acting with others it may be in this
instance we want to get 6:1 parts of it
yes ok Council of drugs Thank You mr.
chair I think also it might be no idea
we've not seen this signal better but I
think it might be not do if their
acknowledgement that if it doesn't
already out fully outlines to the
petitioner their options bearing him
bearing in mind the number of signatures
that they've got what does the letter I
think that if it doesn't count
that signal is ready now oh it's a
procedure later
yeah we've received your petition we're
putting it out take all the dates I
think we want to to consider what could
be a you know an understandable
communication you know it you know for
petitioners I mean it is the case that
when a petitions received there are
numerous options you know that can be
found that sort of this did at the
moment in the condo there's a number
there is a possibility taken in a way
it's finding a way that a petitioner
feels comfortable with the information
they're receiving they feel they can ask
any questions and it's and it's worded
in plain English in the Constitution in
acknowledgement acknowledgement advise
the petitioner way to find that in the
Constitution well I mean in in the
eighth and an acknowledgement it would
be indicated that there are you know
that there's various considerations that
the council can give but again it's
about keeping it just sort of keeping it
simple isn't it in terms of general
understanding we'd want to look at that
I think yeah sure that they keep it as
simple appeals with wise petitioner
because what we haven't well the options
that are available to the council
they're listed in this reporting any of
it the council can do any number of
things including refer it to other
bodies and does the petitioner petition
and now that is it clear to them what
those options are when do you think it
could be made clearer I think we'd like
to look at whether it whether it whether
it can be made clearer as part of how
the wording and the Constitution could
be could be more easily accessible
notwithstanding references to
legislation that
to counsel standing can I get this
that's it or doesn't it give options to
the petitioner when you send the email
of confirmation and and also have been
altered the wording does that
petitioning get that said to it before
is put forward the options that the
council has when it's dealing with the
petition are are in the Constitution and
I'm a petitioner they're not the options
for the petitioner they're the options
that the council has and the petitioner
should be aware of that and we want them
to be aware of that in terms of in terms
of if there is any if there is any
adjustment to wording that's proposed by
petitioner and it's important that they
think on that and you know they might
not want to change it if there is any
suggestion only bits suggested it would
be with a view to I've got a jump in
it's not that the petitioner has changed
the wording is the cancer has changed
the wording for the petitioner and does
the chasm does it or doesn't it give
direction to the petitioner on the the
return of saying that we have got your
petition just say yes or no I mean
that's all I want if it doesn't then
we've got to do something if it does
then that's fine you've done it but
that's it doesn't give the petitioner he
sought for the case or to take different
different views or different agent the
petitioner needs to know where the
cancer is going and if the council
doesn't forward that information they
don't know what they're doing
think of the moment your son is at the
moment
not including its interruptions that the
council has on how it deal with the
petition are to be found in the
Constitution I think always that now is
a recommendation probably is that
whether the council needs to consider
how it makes those options clear to the
organizer position whether that's
included in the acknowledgement or what
the reference is made to depart the
Constitution that the partition
organizer needs to you can drop that by
the 27th is the inclusion of the
relevant acts and whether you could also
give review review them how the petition
organizer is informed of the options
that the council may take with you guys
to petition I'm not disagreeing but I
think there's one forming for units that
I am more concerned clean actually in
the petition it's at the same time I
wasn't at full council so I can't I
don't know what we said but most of you
here were and where there was a petition
which the water district council decided
would be heard at full council rightly
or wrongly I'm not debating here at
least obviously within the council's
gift and they decided that was the best
option and I'm not criticizing that
decision but I'm concerned that is part
of that petition was risen to its demand
that this interesting house where fully
costed proposals three percentage now we
have a petition
requesting something and we're debating
it and from everything I'm hearing that
part of the petition was totally ignored
now can I have it am i right it was that
specific if that has not been but part
of the petition hasn't been addressed
then obviously the petitioner has a
complaint under the process and I think
that's quite serious the point is
earlier my sanity believed the frostings
to destroy them costumes would have come
forward had members held the petition is
accurate yes I'd have to read the the
proud of the petition again but but yes
if if if their degree the petition then
there would have been a need for fully
costed proposals to be to be drawn up
and brought to Council
yeah Sherman I'd need to look at the
tray of the petition against
I don't agree that that is the way we
should be interpreting petition as I
understand it the reason the costs were
presented is because the advice for the
petitioners got was not make the
presentation of the costs that
particular a particular request of the
petition so had those words been
included and the council hadn't omitted
them if you like then Apple council all
those costs would have been presented so
to me what goes back to and it gets back
to singularly is what we've been talking
about for the last 10 to 15 minutes
which is a clear understanding of the
petitioner as to the correct wording
that needs to be used to achieve the
basis of what a lay person wants to us
so mr. chairman but it says here that
the detail the petition is that I've
just read it out for the decision
[Music]
perhaps we can have some clarity here
we've got the petition overview and then
the detail which asks for fully costed
proposals goody
those those Brady systems again by the
counsel Weather Channel it doesn't ask
for someone an officer to actually
present it and as I understand
everything I've read the words are
required to say and I require and we
require an officer to present those
those costings so the absence of those
words is exactly what caused this not to
be presented in full counsel and that in
my opinion and then seemingly in the
opinion of everybody else who was
addressed it recently in this meeting is
to say we didn't give enough information
and appropriate information to the
petitioner which goes back to getting it
right in the Constitution and any
associated letters and entries on our
website mr. Bostock is that something
that you can advise the committee that
won't be
but he looked at in the future because
worthy of petitions of court letting the
campuses and advice on why does it need
to be terminal although let's say is
that the responses to the questions
we've had RS set out on on the paper the
only changes in consultation with the
petitioner in this case were those three
words and the further detail on page six
point three Roger District Council's
once and ends upon local residents and
visitors and does include this is
addressed in council we're fully foster
proposals would be presented for the
crowns of the toilets in the first
instance that petition the petition was
put before council and notwithstanding
that it had been discussion with the
petitioner
then those sort of things could have
been teased out the if the petition had
been agreed then fully costed proposals
would have had to have come forward
however you know understanding the
nation going forward
what the issue that related is that if
the council are advising as he organizes
as regards of wording off the petition
used they really cannot be any ambiguity
within that it's really best not to have
ambiguity yes Terry I might point that
when I make when the petitioner is
allowed to speak at a full council
meeting unlike here I'm allowed you're
allowing me to interact there is no
chance for the petitioner to make any
substance of supplementary comments
after it's made his presentation whilst
the debate is going on some of these
issues that occurred in the debate I was
sitting and seething there was no way
that I could say anything I did heckled
once politicals
got slapped down so maybe the
Constitution should be changed also that
when the petition goes to the full
council the petitioner is allowed to
make presentation and to our primary
questions
yes children it's it's it's about yeah
that's right I just want to suggest that
as we have a communication strategy we
have tell me more and what we do all
this in the spirit of that that's you
know make use of that facilities that
way and we've got priority in
transparency that really wouldn't be
probably having having less problems in
the future if we want to look at that
way and it's certainly policy this
council to improve communications it's
an issue with really this comes with
that getting advice it's almost like
saying that someone will be an advisor
or an ailment as it were for some member
of the public coming into up serious
question which is to go down the road do
we do we do actually hold ourselves as
transparent and helping residents in our
communication on whatever emails we put
put together and what have you
nothing it hasn't come to the forefront
of this particular issue and I think
there's something which we should be
opening up a new you know you need to be
an opening one and what you say these
needs correct you recommend ice is that
this community's making
oh wait mr. Thomas again I'll be miss
happy conclusion recommendations are you
ignoring the system of testing and the
system not being fit for purpose but I
think it's ignoring a lot of the testing
of is out of our hands as a council
response that was given to you for me
personally yeah I spent 13 years as a
software developer thanks a rubbish that
was a rubbish answer okay that's fully
respect that for me I have no questions
inside I want to be completely
transparent because I believe I've seen
comments from Council officers on that
very question I believe it's been
addressed
I believe members were advised that he
was addressed
I believe members were advised that the
testing the subsequent testing revealed
that there were issues with the software
and the software supplier has undertaken
further development work to close those
those those error points and the council
will I assume will will have now
completed a user acceptance test on that
software to ensure that duplicates and
cannot be introduced in another way not
previously so that it's been completely
transparent because you know the answer
you would have seen in the papers isn't
everything that the members have had and
it wasn't more confidential so I'm
believing you
thank you very much has been just
bothers me to be well aware of Boehner's
questions all the answers that were
given we've had a lot of political
announce of committing understanding
exchanges such for the to those which
may be resolved some of the or answer
some of the questions that were asked if
I could have to start with cameras was
services maintenance to members that
haunted the Eliza meaning just to ask
mrs. Mason to take the lead on this okay
chasm is expected so this evening we
have rings and most sisters yes first I
think we explained in the free meeting
how this occurred and it was a an
unfortunate result I will say partly
unfortunate result of the chances I take
situation where doesn't give receipts or
nourishment so we have to rely on that
and then I'm sure counselor mr. Mason
has taken it up with don't try and
understand that it's being looked at so
that going forward there won't be so
much difficulty having said that I'm
very unhappy that the portfolio holder
is not here and I would very much like
to think doing in response to the
questions that I've given her you can
see here these are the remaining was has
been very full and comprehensive
response is unfortunately the final
response came in thirsty and we were not
we were away for it it's my birthday so
we were later we came so I hadn't had
time to go through the finer ones but
there's just a couple of three things
really that are outstanding that I would
like some thought further clarity on
further consideration the initial report
gave a saving of a hundred and thirty
one thousand pounds I don't want to go
into the detail of how that was yes and
I now understand that it was like a
grocer saving without the cost of the
debts that's been incurred but I do
think it should be made clear and
reports that that is an estimated saving
and not an actual saving and that is
something that I would not consider so
than that
I could go into detail I think that
that's something that's important that
we would note it's not money that we
have actually saved is money that we
think we have explained which is a
different perspective from an accounting
point of view anyway I was concerned
about the level of debt which is 50% of
the cases outstanding and I can
understand that these people are
difficult situation but I can't think of
any other situation where 50% of
situations would be you know dect
situation it does seem to me that the
criterion perhaps needs to be looked at
so that's a question whether that is
being looked at and the finals before
the final point I'm sure
Raisa can clarify this for good
I have an issue where you're saying but
there's a disconnect between no history
of eviction for a property in the last
three years because of predatory is I'm
sure you couldn't be saying this one
it's not clear because as if actually is
not always a result of rent arrears and
the attention to the infants to it
written so for rent movies and you've
said no systems for professional funding
will be considered for clients who have
a history of rent arrears but if we're
lending the rent arrears but they may
not have benefited I mean that there is
the if there was a lack clarity and
illness I just I think you'll understand
so you'll say if someone has put a can
then use whatever clients ready to they
can't pay it then they have got
definition a history of rental is
so there's a slight contradiction there
but I think we need some planets here
I mean just on that point and I can
understand the confusion when reading
the policy because as you say one but it
quite was saying it with it as a history
of regiments we won't be persistent and
then in another paragraph
almost immediately after us were saying
or we charge for an element is for rent
arrears and and I understand I mean I've
had a bit of an epiphany myself I'm
thinking that's not very clear so I
think I need to go back and work that a
bit differently because I think I've
explained in the questions the the rent
arrears comes about is when normally as
you say we always look at the history
and when a client comes in and says over
something like the nanos put the red
tarp and we can no longer afford it and
I know for a period of time we've just
fallen down so there's no history it's
just that an immediate response to not
being able to afford the rent of it is
now so I think what I need to do is
clarify that because anyone looking at
this on the internet and internet go
forward it's going to say while we rent
arrears I'm just going to go and get
some money and get it topped up and
that's not what this is about answer yes
oh I'll go away in clarify nice but
we're still going to be given it for
those circumstances where people do fall
in rent arrears because of the
unexpected unanticipated increase in
rent by the landlord which is quite
common to tell the truth and can we look
at the criteria for actually lending
because the percentage of 50 %
well I think at the moment as I said I
think the outstanding amount is about
22,000 I mean it I mean obviously I
could have get a vice firm unless you
know me but I mean that's I mean it's
ongoing but obviously it goes into the
debtors situation and then they do
follow-up letters leave or get involved
etc then I don't know the final outcome
that is but I think it's pretty good I
mean I'm not too sure how we can amend
this criteria any further and then it's
all based on budget planning if it's not
as if the clients can't afford it it's
their choice at the other day and I I
mean it and it does make it awkward for
us because we just want to reduce that
debt as much as possible because we
don't want these people coming back into
our service because it creates further
problems thank you
and the final question mr. chairman if
I'm Mary I think that's clarified that
as far as we're able but thank you for
that Mary's but the the point and that
this is not a point ringing that I think
the assistant director should be
responding to this is the point I would
like a written response from where you
hold on this we're like relates to
sexual 7 1996 of a housing homeless
backed out yet what members may or may
not be aware that when a person has
what's called an assured foot hole
Tennessee it there's a limit to that and
at any time the landlord for no reason
no fault of the tenant can give notice
and the notice is called a section 21
line test which gives 56 days two months
roughly two months notice to leave the
property now at that point in time the
tenant is aware that they have to vacate
and it is difficult to find often a
similar property within their budget
with their special needs they may have
children and they have pets and
landlords can and are after a very fussy
from that point of time it is covered in
this report but I'm not content that we
are being fair to our residents but when
that happens these people become
homeless not because they've done
anything wrong because they're in a
situation that
get out our policy at the moment is
generally to tell them to stay put
we've actually know the situation the
where and I got great status but don't
want to go to too much theater with a
family with a mother and children were
actually had to wait before we would
assist them they had to wait until the
providers defender and that is it would
appear to be generally our policy that
we wait once that served 56 status of
the land or then goes to call and his
obsession powder and it doesn't have to
be again anything wrong now the law
actually states and the code states the
authorities should note that the fact
that a tenant has a right to remain in
occupation does not mean that he or she
is not homeless and that relates
particularly to that part of the Act
so there has noticed and I know that we
in speak we can and a prevention tries
to perhaps get the landlord to stay on
but generally speaking we know at that
point in time that we will should or may
have a duty in 56 days wouldn't concern
that is that we seem to we seem to have
a general policy of telling our
residents to stay fit but stasis things
where they are in seats you now can
understand that for a financial point if
it makes absolute sense it's a
no-brainer but we're not talking just
about far as we're talking about
children we're talking about people the
stress that they're under is
unbelievable and at the end of the day
what I don't know if this is Jeremy now
when they go to cold because if they
have a procession all of them land or
has a procession from land or not you do
it that first tenet end up with the
catechol judgment week or he doesn't do
much good for their future prospects of
renting but the land you'll can actually
climb back the costs of that court
action because it was unnecessary
because that they've broken
contract so we're putting it a fun
durable person into debt and through
stress through our policy and it's that
aspect that I would like to hear that
portfolio holders feel because I know
it's covered in your report to some
extent but I don't think that we are
being fair to those very people in that
difficult situation we should not be
saying to someone sit there until until
your annual gets a court order and the
bailiffs comes around so what you asking
just depend yours gonna put very holder
to confirm Delaware
you just explained to the committee and
what that's it explained that they're
aware of it and I want them to clarify
their policy on it because in the
document here it is not that we should
be code this is a code says we should
not adopt a general policy we should and
as I say if they remain an occupation at
56 days there's not mean that they're
not harmless I mean there's a there's a
lot more to it than that I said this is
a simplified version but I'd like the
portfolio hold it to look at that aspect
of the code and to compare it with the
policy that he has endorsed and
hopefully improve it so that our
residents though not subject to
unnecessary stress and further costs
that they can't avoid you can and wonder
if Louise it could tell us that what
points does the count from how that you
okay someone in that circumstance I
think I mean as ice is responsible to
cancel mrs. Mason it's really it's not
to lieutenant even required to vacate
the property and as counsel mrs. Mason
said that sometimes can be at the time
of the warrant and the only thing I
would say is that obviously government
has recognizes that you know this does
sometimes happen and as you say it does
cause undue sometimes stress regardless
of where we can support and the homeless
production actors will bring these kind
of scenarios a little bit tighter as in
we've got a duty now to you we've got a
longer time to prevention and there's a
stronger duty under these circumstances
where there is a risk of homelessness so
we would be stepping in at a much
earlier point when we are at the moment
can I come back home I mean that's not
the answer but what I'm saying is yeah
thank you it would seem that this
there's potential from advice that might
be given to someone that they might be
advised to do something which from
ultimately cause them not necessarily at
that time at some time in the future to
seriously affect their financial
position
in relation to their credit rating so if
you us as a council and our officers
need to be careful about how we advise
people in those circumstances because it
could have a detrimental effect on their
future financial district sorry
counselor mr. Boyd I just need you to
speak next yeah now I just wanted to
write them and when you do a credit
check
yeah also you do do credit check if
someone's coming
chief I presume you don't charge him for
that something Oh percentage would you
say that they would need to actually get
cuz I'm tell me if you do it credit kid
all right fires credit loans and
probably be 98 point whatever something
because no one ever gets hundreds in
Dimona though something so them because
these people obviously they they come to
you concerning dire straits because I
can't afford the ring oh you're going to
give them a loan so what percentage of a
credit check we say then you know mean
with their yeah I mean I'll tell you on
this score high yeah I mean to be honest
with you I don't do those checks
oh I mean obviously they do do credit
checks for actually to put it bluntly
they sort of take out you know they go
through the bank statements you know
they go find the details of what their
outgoings are what they've got coming in
and sort of in basic terms or balance
the two and see what does those will
income they've got though it's a little
bit more personalized than
ready check if you see what I mean but
they will go through everything itself
for well I don't know monthly payments
have got out Christmas club staff you
know activity is you know they really go
to the finer details and talk to the
clients as to what's really necessary
what's desirable one was absolutely
you're saying you don't give it money
through credit check if you think about
it's not like you go in together if
you're going on Thank You counselor
listen listen thank you having iodides
go back to this section 21 situation the
reason though is all about this because
we have exchanged correspondence with it
several months ago and I rather hopes
that the homelessness prevention Act
would do a great deal more than it is
doing and I think our policy needs to be
reconsidered I think putting it into
this sort of scrutiny environment and
asking the portfolio to reconsider it
really does focus on other aspects of
section 21 so do you have a situation
where you have a tenant tenant with a
partner or with a family they have faced
with a section 21 which is basically an
eviction notice they're advised by the
council to remain that causes stress and
ultimately as crisp as council this is
Mason has explained we can end up with
the costs of cord and bailiffs added to
the whole situation worse than that and
this is what I want to emphasize to you
guys it would ease worse than that
if they decided to vacate the property
without being evicted okay so we say our
council policies you stayed until the
bailiff turns up and me pushes you out
of the door so if you go earlier than
that and the reason AUSA's confirm this
to me then we can consider that person
as having motivate themselves
intentionally homeless we can now that
to me this despite Louisa explains we
will look at each case I think there's
something wrong with a council that is
doing that and he's wrong or a council
that knows about the code from the DCL
gene it was Brandon Lewis it was there
at the time
it's it's clearly available we are
subscribing to a money saving situation
rather than the welfare of residents of
our district and Louisa said this is
something which is increasing to put
someone in a position where they can be
made to have the stigma and the actual
situation the actual status of
intentionally homeless means we do
nothing ever for so I go further and say
this whole section 21 thing does need a
reconsideration by the portfolio holder
and I would like to think for this
council and would like to do better for
our residents and it is the purpose and
proper action of a review committee of
scrutiny Motiti to bring this to the
attention of the portfolio holder when
it is not clear that they know this
Thank You councillor Gittings this is a
question to employees there is that some
kind so you know what's coming forward
in April for the homeless so would you
knowing that's coming forward would you
be able to act upon that now or do you
need to wait till April so bear in mind
what's been pointed out already would
you be able to nip it in the bud at
notice of course so mean it's about
early intervention and it's about that
you say you know someone could come
through the door and we can say stay
code but it don't mean I have to say is
quite rare that we wouldn't then give
immediate advice and start intervening
but it's about you know adopting an
early intervention approach perhaps a
couple months early before April which
will have to do come back on that I can
honestly tell you it has happened we
have sat on our hands with the family
Louisa knows exactly who I'm talking
about and I'm not going to reveal them
reveal their name and circumstances on a
part of a public recording so we
basically yes they we did nothing we
told them they could do nothing
we told the landlord Lincoln but there
was nothing the council could do the
landlord had to proceed to a possession
order and incur the costs of court
action and a bailiff and it was all too
late so you know when you win you're
told
oh it hasn't happened it has it has and
that's what bothers me
and how many more times it could can
happen
and that's what I find out about mr.
chairman that's not the onion
contradictory I'm telling you it's
happened
counsel mr. Fuchida Semyon it has
happened that you are not well ID as you
say we can't reveal the details in this
public meeting detail well clearly if
you say yes pick up but I personally
can't remember that I'm sure I will be
able to memory if I've got the details
right yes you know you can't some base
that says I've converse with him without
that it was a case and the council
months and the Landlord got so upset
with the council they actually engage
directly we make they wanted to engage
with the Phonographic but it wasn't
possible I don't know why which is why I
can eat I wanted to go back to the
portfolio holders to address the issue
councillor Stanek Thank You chairman a
couple of things come to mind but I'm
reading through these in as much as
where the council offers advice and a
deposit for the rooms bedrooms 2 3 & 4
that's for one month's read file I've
shown
only one month's rating is that good
though right it's what is is it's just a
way to posit boys yeah so so if the
applicant can't come up with the with
the rent that is to the do they are they
able to get another month right so we're
looking at that situation where does the
where does that person go because
obviously that if you're on a monthly
paid basis and you're in debt in any
case because this is where you are with
the cancel you've got to pay off your
debts or whatever it is it's it's hard
for you to afford the second month's
rate so if that doesn't come across and
and this is where we're getting to areas
where they could be evicted are they
able to pick up anything from the
council after one month so that they can
disturb you mean it takes time to get
yourself established on your faith and
everything in the way if you've been
evicted and what have you and you
O'Malley and what and you've got you've
got survived somehow not only have you
got rent to pay we've got electricity
gas and phone bills and you've got a
family and what have you it doesn't seem
such a it seems to me to be very little
time for you to get established on your
feet and I wonder if we could extend it
on a three monthly basis is that and Oh
find that I realized that if you can't
you're going to be in trouble again
because you're not having it's not
giving the time for the person if he
gets paid monthly isn't he's just not
going to be able to to make it I know
this is a fact and so the cage sees that
in Kansas that way most of the questions
well because the question is I says I
see we've got the prices there that sort
of thing and it's an interest-free loan
but it's only a one month free loan if
you like so are you asking I'm asking
I'm asking if it's possible to extend
that no this is for rent deposit or
renting the van yeah no it's a really
positive purpose so it's not their
monthly payment but it's just me but
they still got paid but you know
absolutely we're not going to be given a
rent deposit or rent in advance loan if
we don't think the client going forward
can pay their monthly rent payment
that's all part of the budget planning
process
I see so it decently just a one-off
payment so we think if they can't if
they come to you in time and say that
they you know they can't the landlord
will obviously take the money here that
a solid sprint but is that you allocated
to that person and they can't pay the
next month's you're not going to so they
will be basically section 21 will the
beer will be out on their ear in 30 days
is that we don't we won't be not going
don't we're not going backwards instead
of forwards a housing advisory
conversation isn't it we're not going to
be entering into financial incentives
for someone that can't afford it going
forward and as I say fermenter election
21 then we're going to have to have a
further conversation about what that
means for them we're putting somebody
back in the homeys
I bought yet but I think I can
understand the contradiction here the
one month payment is a deposit that's
paid for the land rule because the
tenant hasn't got that amount of money
but they don't have to pay it back in a
month they do it what's called a
financial statement if I understand
correctly which is all their incoming
and outgoing which proves that they can
pay the monthly rent plus a proportion
back to that rent deposit so it might be
ten pound it might be 20 pound so
they've been paying their rent plus I
mean only a contribution back of 10
pounds or 20 pence always paid back I
think that was the case that money had
to be put back into the key which brings
me to the second question how much is
the cancel allow allowing for debt to
occur what is the top limit for the
castle on debt to occur it will be legal
to advise I think each case individual I
don't know what collectively ladies from
for the year sort of things so
collectively what is your top limit or
do you not have a limit well I mean
there's no sense limit on how much debt
we could incur in relation to this
specific you might mean we set out what
right and we're sort of recovering at it
at the moment but yeah there's no actual
sort of set limits about how much grant
possibly be not paid back there no
counselor mrs. makes enough people to
come back on that yes I'd like to come
back on that point there is a debt limit
because the budget is 50,000 so the
limit is logically fifty thousand we've
already said that half of that spirit
right was twenty-two thousand
outstanding so there is a debt limit
debt limit per person but to the council
on the colonel yes there is
thank you yeah well obviously the deck
incurred couldn't exceed the amount that
we've landed but my dad didn't make
myself specifically clear but yeah but
in terms of the limit you would
obviously have to be a hundred percent
yeah
the amounts been thank you Joe and his
son on the basis of phone absolutely
Mason stated about fifty percent we
announced standing there has
have you considered for the department
considered what is the safe debt margin
what you boys you prepared to now that
they lived the act and is there with the
increasing number of homeless necessary
things so there's a potential from from
more of this law requiring this scheme
these second a lot more pressure on on
their on 27th and possibly gradually
increase the level of thickness or do
not count that way and how have you
protected going forward yeah I apologize
I can't answer he squeezed to be about
the debt because it goes through our
debtors and legal
can you advise on that debt level well
the debt level will be no more than the
fifty thousand pound budget are we we
set a prevention budget of circa fifty
thousand pound and we said you could
potentially allowed to go to hundreds in
potentially but we budget for five that
the edge of budget their budgets for
five thousand pounding come back but in
this case we can do better than that
five thousand-pound budget but the
budget allows for you deposit a single
shade right 209 a week I mean do you
think these figures are not coming can
you you're saying that the amount you're
paying a monthly upfront then they're
just pay off gradually um well in
Rayleigh can you can you ring a prefect
of towson lady for a m10 pair what
happens if did they come to you and say
look I've looked everywhere
raining yeah I'll get anywhere near I
under the temp and amount would you then
up here all inflexibly at that
okay I think would be asking portfolio
holder to come back well counsel mr.
spacely's talked about a great in
response because I you you wanted me to
response for someone to come back
German that was considered and it was
only a consideration prize to be super
at the meeting he's because obviously
one doesn't hold up a policy there's
gonna be benefit residents who are
already vulnerable so there was a there
was a thought that said you know it
needed to be called in because of events
but then at this committee we've we know
that there are issues that do need to be
resolved there are issues
Louise Abbas has already resolved so
that makes it easy for the committee to
track that she does what she's told
she's going to do but the issue of
section 21 I think is is is almost
separate although it's included within
the prevention policy so
we could do this one or two ways as you
suggest we could have a written reply
from the book vocal that has to the
counselors policy and all aspects of
section 21 and the DC LG's advice and
whether or not
further consideration for change of the
previous policy as possible and we can
have that back well we can have units we
can have it back as individual members
of the review committee when the
portfolio holder actually decides
because what we're asking the poor
family harder to actually do is we know
what the current policy is to reconsider
the policy as a result of this this
report you're in depending I'm happy
with that I'm hoping that enables those
who would benefit from this policy will
do so immediately
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's quite a few aspects to it if
there's any way that you can just
perhaps we've all had a chance to read
us a new script a five-minute summary so
as you indicated the purpose of this
meet the ultimate this meeting is to
discuss the proposed capsule in treasury
management strategy for 1819 and decide
whether you're happy to recommend it to
all council next week you'll be aware
from the paper that the strategy has
been expanded to include not only
treasury management but also our
proposed approach to our capital
management as well and that's and like
the in relation to the guidance issued
by slipped on the potential code of
capital finance and the treasury
management code of practice which
originally fishing shortly before
Christmas
so the reason it's been expanded is to
meet our statutory requirements around
that area the intention of the
government issuing the guidance is to
try and strengthen the relationships
between our what we spend our money on
in terms of our capital program and a
wider investment strategy and I know
there's been some questions that
previous meeting about the distinction
between the best mistake for treasury
management purposes and potential for
investments made
purposes and the guidance does set out
to make para what not distinction
between Isis and the approach that
counsel should take in terms of those so
yeah the the guidance does that clear
distinction between investments at hold
for treasury management purposes which
is basically for cash cash flow purposes
and other investments particularly in
relation to the sort of commercial
agenda that some councils have been
taken at IO again we've discussed their
previous meeting in addition to that the
strategy does make reference to and is
depending on guidance from what was
called to the Department for Communities
and Local Government arounds and such to
guidance on local government investments
and that guidance actually was issued
just a couple of days ago so it's not
reflected in the strategy at the moment
although having had a literary through
it I think we are broadly compliant with
the requirements of that guidance as
well and actually we're not obliged to
formally adopt laughs until 1920 anyway
although we've rights have been complied
with best practices in terms of
including at 18 19 so essentially the
strategy sets out how with you know our
governance processes for approving and
monitoring our capital expenditure as in
previous versions of the strategy it
sets our capital financing requirement
and then sets our policies for making
there
any prudent provision of any debts
although as members will know at this
time they're like oh she doesn't want to
take any borrowing so that's it not
though its consideration for us at this
point in time it also sets out the
Capitol's sorry without the council's
approach to treasury management
investments and the criteria for how we
invest our funds of treasury management
purposes and the proposed strategy as it
stands is consistent with that applied
in previous year so we've not altered
our lens inglis criteria at this time so
I would just point then to the appendix
that you referenced at the start and
again in its relation to questions we've
had a previous meetings about whether we
should revise our strategies to
incorporate sorry to continue to have
their provision to lend to other local
authorities so we didn't respond off the
November investment fraud sorry December
Investment Board meeting when a specific
question was raised having now taken
some professional advice from our
treasury management advisors and also
and has taken some sort of help in has
both activity with our other local
authorities and local authorities to see
what they will approach they take it's
our it's our offices offices view in
conjunction obviously I'm speaking with
our portfolio holder the advice would be
that we continue to have the sorry if
little said so let's have the capacity
to lend to other local authorities to
continue to be an are lending lists but
obviously that is subject to the
approval of this committee so we'll
obviously willing to answer questions
and have a discussion around that point
if members feel that they do want to
revise the strategy to take out that
specific provision but at the moment
it's our advice that that should
continue
especially so that's what I would say
it's time to say I think thank you very
much captain mr. myson Thank You
chairman thank you Amy for talking about
the appendix
well you'd guess I've given that a lot
of thought and I gave you a lot of
thought even before we wrote all of the
appendix was put out now of course since
you wrote that we've heard all about
Northampton and we've heard about the
speculation about 10 other councils in
difficulties or yes now initially we did
difficulties I think this was another
almost the words the Guardian used so
it's far more widespread than just
Northampton and that was what I was
concerned about when I originally raised
this several meetings ago so one's
instincts and professional instincts are
right and I feel comfortable with that
I've predicted all sorts of unfortunate
things happening in finance and they do
happen you know wins when somebody
starts bidding up interest rates you the
professionals know there's usually
something wrong there is dire need of
money and they can't get it from the
sources they would normally get it from
and therefore they bid they big hire to
attract investors and that's exactly
what happened in Iceland and latterly in
Cyprus and we all know where those
situations end we've got to be very very
careful if we were to just accept a few
a few extra points on the interest that
may not go anywhere near our weighing
the risk the extra risk risk that we're
taking and although it's said that no
government would leave another council
indebted from another and not step in I
get the feeling it might be some time
before
happened and then we'd have to find our
own financing rate to do that we may
answer the list of those councils in
difficulties and you know I don't want
to get into that cycle I would be
totally released given my background my
professional knowledge to allow this
council to do that or if it does want to
do that it'll do it without me and it
will do it with a recorded vote
so when it comes to putting your hands
in your pockets you don't have to but
for you when you might do put your hands
in your pockets you'll do so because
it's deadly serious this I've looked at
the options that have been put forward
the easy one is to say let's not let's
take it out let's take that category of
borrower out because that way you can't
get into any trouble because you're not
going to consider it there's issues
around diversity of of people you can
lend to well frankly we've only been to
banks recently anyway I'm not entirely
sure what diversity has given us so I
think I come back to the situation where
I'm speculated about that isn't a form
of credit rating for local authorities
and it's interesting with a link
previous nomes capita consider that they
can establish a scheme of braiding or
very raising of local authorities in the
same way as they do banks I've got to
honestly say to you that you know I've
been a member of the council for us for
a lot of time and I tend to understand
how this council's finance works and how
the council's finance works and it's
taken a long time to the bat and I know
it takes a long time for our
professionals to learn their tune which
is why they're qualified and why their
time serve and why they understand it
I've got some some doubts in my own mind
that whether an external agency an
external consultancy can really do this
well enough but because I don't want to
I personally don't want to rule this
category out I'm tending to change my
mind towards the end of last week to
accepting that
let's give link
let's give Cabot are a chump to consider
how they might enter into a a general
and universal scheme for credit rating
local authorities I do think they're
going to find it very difficult and of
course the proof of the pudding on a
credit rating is is homely when it's
improved to be right or wrong and that
is that's enough of all that sort of
analysis if we do go down that route I
am prepared to I don't know what other
members of this committee are prepared
to do and I don't know what for council
is prepared to do but I want to see
every you know I want to see the detail
of the credit reference rating scheme
that they come up with and I'm and I
would like to repeal it personally and
I'd like to look at it with others in
this room who have got financial
experience I know there are quite a
number of others and I'd like to sit
down in the task group on behalf of this
committee and look at it in in great
detail before we
allow review committees to say to full
council okay
let's release the hold upon this
category and let's go with a credit
rating scheme just come back on that
specific point just to make absolutely
clear savants we need up the committee
that link after services don't undertake
credit ratings of individual local
authorities and having spoken and lastly
they've absolutely no intention of doing
that either side I apologize if that
I've caused any ambiguity in the wording
of the report well this is the way I've
read it
okay so it seems quite clear their name
so I've just wasted I'm sorry members
anyway I've just wasted your time
listening to an argument that I thought
was going to be helpful I'm afraid
without a credit without a credit rating
then I'm afraid I am I won't at the
present time I think we shall put a hold
on that category we shall put a hold on
that category for six months to see what
actually happens in the local authority
market and that's the local authority
market for borrowing and lending I'm not
comfortable to recommend to the council
that we get we get involved at this
point we'd Northampton and a Guardian
article talking of ten others
I don't know out of the four hundred how
you gonna guess which ones we've got the
issues so I changed my attend to my own
personal point of view just saying we
put a hold on that some of our category
of lending for six months and leave you
again no I mean yeah that usually when
you gave your party's summary of
everything you said that it was your
recommendation that that particular
element of the pool was kept in
predation that you are comfortable with
it are you able to kind of give the
committee an idea of what is you breach
that sit on how you reach that decision
we've heard from counsel most new
obviously answer in finance for me it's
raised some interesting points in the
same tone the most I can see it's in
there one in your seem comfortable with
that because it's there how did you
reach that decision okay so I appreciate
the points raised and I realized that
the sort of headlines around Northampton
probably have raised some alarm bells
and I suppose my views being formed in
terms of the professional advice and
that we've taken as we said from our
treasury management advisors and also
from speaking to our peer group and the
majority of or virtually or our other
counselors do continue to recommend
lending to other local authorities as an
option within their territory management
strategies I would say that in terms of
the wording of the government's iron
guidance in the investment violence it's
just recently issued it does sort of
classify local authorities alongside
central government in their winders
their list of specified investments and
sort of does give them the same for
kudos in that respect in local
authorities unlike and central
government in that cuts greater their
view is obviously that tree by central
government and local government
investments under the same criteria for
that so I would say that all investments
are obviously have some risk attached
there's never 100% risk-free investment
and that's the same we put everything
that we invest in and the priorities of
our investment strategy haven't trained
so it's always security first then
liquidity then yield but as I say it's
my view that the security is adequate
and in terms of the risks that we can
take a course a balanced portfolio and
in that we would feel
them as positive to the wider investment
and portfolio that we would consider so
yeah that's that's my answer
thank you Thank You chairman um yeah
notice term in the addendum you there
was a number of options listed as
alternatives which which the committee
coupe I ever know anyone that there
isn't a as a big slate today a rating
which perhaps authorities could be
judged by I could give us some kind of
guidance as to be expanding you've come
up with one of the options with us where
other other criteria or other tests
could be enlightened to to ascertain as
to whether a particular proposal was
satisfy and also I'm a parent already in
there that you also stated that
sometimes these these offers come
forward and their timing TV so surely
that option there's a contradiction
there because if you've got a situation
whereby an offer comes forward and it's
time limited you are not going to be in
a position to make these addition
checks says that going to limit the
opportunities that we have in relation
to what comes more so I think if we were
to choose to go down that really we'd
need a sort of an established procedure
of the sort of nature level of checks at
which needs to be undertaken then they
would have to be proportionate as I
indicated in my report I mean also said
in the appendix there's there's not one
approach to how you could do this but I
mean for example you could maintain a
list of authorities that you would not
invest in in any other circumstances so
for example which you could choose to
put North Hamilton to on that list so
you could have a list of authorities
that you wouldn't please to invest and
you could look at for example the audio
pinyin of the accounts for the previous
years and again with Northampton shares
example their accounts have been
qualified so that would you know
potentially you haven't you know red
flag that we really want to invest in
eyes that would be quite quick and easy
check there's potentially all the things
we can do for example sort of balance
sheet review to sort of look at the
trend in terms of their you know balance
sheet position over the last couple of
years which could potentially be a
relatively quick and easy exit it there
are a number of things we could look at
to give us a broad-brush indication of
the financial health of the individual
or authority in which winning it to be
in a huge amount of detail yes so I
think we would need to establish what
those checks would like and we wouldn't
be doing that on an ad sort of plot
basis and as a many investments occurred
so we'd have a you know a framework to
set out how we would do that in advance
or any of this coming through thank you
it's very interesting that there's these
avenues for which you've got the ability
to get information about particular
Authority quite quickly but I would be
interesting in a capsule um your mason
feels that whether that is a safeguard
which is which is of anybody would have
any benefit in to in his opinion the
problem the problem is you're looking at
very static situations and you know you
you can't you don't know what the debt
profile is for a balance sheet and this
they declare everything that's in there
you don't know what other projects
they're undertaking so which require
require borrowing you don't know you
really don't know the ins and outs of
the day-to-day prison circumstances of
over council you don't know that when
you're when you're lending to to
companies or or banks although we thanks
you do have this worldwide established
basis of of credit rating which is
established an established scheme which
has expired we know how to you know
gathered the right information and the
intelligence to from the markets on a
day-to-day basis to put to put against
that what we're asking our our staff to
do is just rely on static information
and it may be considerably as a date or
not complete from the perspective that
you want to do from a credit risk
analysis point of view
I mean banks makes lend to people and I
know they still do even though they love
to do these computer-based assessments
but when it comes down to it you can you
tend to lend to people but you know of
their credit history you know you know a
great deal about them you know you know
they've borrowed before you know what
their credit rating is you look at the
map there's people on Equifax and and
clear score and some of the new ones so
you say you've got a pretty good idea
they're a professional standard analysis
because has taken place you know it was
an established thing when you're lending
to a company and anybody else can put
perfectly right there being let me write
it like wrong I've never linked to a
company purely based on his desktop
financial information you do a great
deal more you have a relationship with
the company you have a relationship with
its financial director you have a
relationship that it's with his
operations with experienced management
and you know what's what's going what's
going on and you and you lend on that
basis okay somebody's gonna say to me
the Karelian was a was a done one but
then hold on a tick I suspect some
people were saying look at all these
government contracts this can't go wrong
and I see these sort of parallels
popping up in local authorities as well
so I'm sorry it's been so long winded I
just wanted to give you a flavor of why
I don't think that's going to be
sufficient I don't think it is going to
be sufficient from stringent an
appropriate standard of approaching
credit analysis and I don't think we
should put other current circumstances
that we we fear staff in that position
thank you I've come along tonight good
start
happy to endorse this this relatively
small change no we're not going to just
weigh Castle Mason tonight I thought
that that's a given easy so he's put out
his case quite clearly but we must
remember that underlying our priorities
about investment as know me as said are
security and liquidity we're not looking
in any of our investment strategies
about high risk high year on high return
quick turnarounds and things we are a
very very cautious investor that's been
a conscious decision that's been made
over a number of years and was endorsed
by review a couple of years ago when
there were wanted to slightly higher
risk suggestions proposed but this is
not a big change in our policy that's
suggested this is just one of a list of
options that available it's not going to
be considered as a principal method of
investing just a option that may or may
not be exercised clearly it's not been
exercised at this point we undertake a
very very careful selection of
investments we do take the professional
advice there is general government
acceptance that investing local
authorities into investing against
either each other is an acceptable form
but local authorities are not finance
institutions what if you use the
criteria to examine finance institutions
to examine local councils district
outsource county councils then you won't
find you're able to make the same sort
of judgments
and that's clearly illustrated by the
fact that there isn't a valid system of
credit rating it just doesn't work but I
think with all those things all in mind
this small change this small option is a
way of us going forward as a way of you
know maximizing our potentials given the
underlying priorities of security and
liquidity and so I'm quite happy to
endorse what we've got here tonight the
reason I want to come back ladies
because I'm going to ask you a financial
question I'm going to say okay how much
more interest in pounds shillings and
pence I'm still that way inclined are
you going to earn from lending to a
local authority than a fully credit
rating bank you know how much more
interest are you going to get and how
much more money does that mean and then
I'll ask you to say is that word risk
worth taking because if it goes wrong
you may not have security and you
remember you certainly won't have
liquidity well so give me the numbers I
will answer that by saying if I knew
exactly how much money I would get back
where when and how
then I'd simply take take my own savings
invest it and clearly become very rich
very quickly because that if you know
exactly what you're going to get paid
back and where those best breaks will be
then that's an it that's an easy Jimmy
King also ago we were told that local
authorities are offering hiring
right Sabathia that's the attraction if
it's a higher interest rate then what is
it because we must know already and we
must know how much more that is which we
are going to learn that we also
concerned about and want to take this
risk for it I can add to that chairman
if I may and just to give you a flavor
an example of interest rates than our
offer this morning if we kept money in
overnight how much more money do we get
for 3 million for five billion hours we
go
not much is it guys it's not much no I
mean I'm saying the risk on these I'm 20
I also love it hello it's taken to
calculate just for the sake of the
committee all chemical you can you say
it's take a figure that you've well I
don't think is appropriate to say that
figure it is not an exercise in anything
in calculation sit here and allow me
it's not chairman Issa this is just a
ploy try and catch something out we're
talking about accepting a ploy from a
non-financial portfolio holder what just
calm down you don't know how to
calculate the differentials of interest
rates there's something wrong just calm
down
just one question I wonder why for at
the moment if we are as you statement
nothing I've got no reason to disagree
with you quite cautious counsel and this
is a strategy that we've not entered
into before at this current time when
it's publicly known that there are other
local authorities in difficulty I'm
assuming that this really wouldn't even
be an avenue that we would be looking to
to go down anyway so I'm mindful what
the moment is why is it so important for
counsel for this to still be included
it's not included in the past I'm sorry
can you repeat the questions I have
sorry at a time now when it's obviously
spot
but there are local authorities that are
in financial difficulty as we've already
alluded there's already negative and
stated that we are cautious council yeah
why would this be a strategy or
something we would look to invest in now
obviously there's a difference of 0.4%
agenda I get that okay but I would just
reiterate that the primary reason for
keeping the option on the lending list
was not for financial return that that's
the third sort of criteria under which
really as we said it's security
liquidity then yield so here it isn't
the primary since you and official news
here MC is the first yes it's I think as
I sort of alluded to in my report I mean
I know there's been some press recently
about the financial position of local
authorities but we have had the land we
have had them on the lending lists up to
this point and add opium it's been a
significant deterioration just in the
last 12 months compared to financial
position of local authorities previously
so I in terms of the risk of what
members are prepared to accept obviously
we set our risk reset our treasury
management strategy in light of members
opinions on the risk appetite of the
council so we have to take that on board
so if the view that I'm hearing around
the room is that the risk appetite is
such that you don't want to do that then
obviously we can take that on board and
amend the strategy all I would say that
it's not a deviation from our previous
strategy which members have been happy
to endorse which is that we have had
local authorities on the lending list
although we have chosen not to eggs
as our option up till now so it's not a
change in our policy it's just a
continuation of our existing policy but
if Memphis sort of risk appetite has
become more risk-averse or in light of
information though feels come to life in
recent weeks
are you mr. blossom one area yeah yeah
then then obviously we need to take that
on board and adopt it within our our
strategy so I'm happy to take Memphis
advice which is the purpose of why we've
had the discussion this evening so I
mean it's up to now I'm going to call it
a recorded vote on this just I said
other members have indicated so I'm just
giving you notice I'm calling your
recording low okay count this particular
issue councillor Stanley thank you Kevin
I'm surprised that we we can't come up
with a finger straight away on the
because we are dealing with finances and
it's only a few pounds 120,000 on three
million so I'm surprised you haven't
come up with it just like that at the
same time the option the option is do we
keep it or W keep it that is the option
what your tunes now if we keep it it
will come back - sorry 1.2 million sorry
hundred - anybody get back today if we
keep it if we do keep let's say we do
does it come back to review as to
whether what does it go to for counsel I
don't know and then something would be
the Chairman Moyles or that as to
whether who we lend it to where does
that go so are you asking that we would
come back to committee with a list of
authorities that we would be prepared
and then yes yeah basically yeah without
that that wasn't one of the options we
put forward I mean where does this um
what does this option give voice avoid
zero science option
options in that one yeah so the options
we've listed five options in their
report but I'll see it wouldn't really
be impractical so in my view to keep
bringing out a list back view committee
for authorization right I mean we could
come up with a list of potential
authorities that we didn't already did
one save investment you want to take
that sorry members please an officer me
speaking but yeah that wasn't that
wasn't one of the proposed options of
this before Graeme rightly and appendix
counselors Thank You mr. chairman
security the quiddity
you and yet there is no valid way of
checking the security of a local
authority you've said that there's no
credit rating looks like the only
information that is please don't enjoy
the only information is historic and
that has been clearly pointed out the
subject I don't accept it's a small
change so security isn't there because
we've only got very historic information
which it's not that liquidity dubious
because if your securities now you're
the quiddity school yeah so you're
pointing to point two two point six if
you look at it another way but it's
three times the amount if you look at it
from risk elements if you were looking
at it on a personal basis and you were
investing your money and you were
offered one percent here and the three
percent there you would know that was a
very high risk so don't look at the
amount which is negligible actually in
in terms of risk if they're offering
that much differential that risk is
three times as high do we want that risk
no we don't so I think option five and
thank you for the information because
the information you've give
has clarified my mind on the options the
option 5 is is the one to go for Thank
You Sachin
following on from the council spend
these people trying together he's
actually who who is the person who makes
the decision who is the one he's going
to make the decision as to whether as
part of a strategy he's going to allow
lending to a local authority is it a
matter these in the remit of one of the
offices or is it something that the
portfolio holder is going to decide in
Council standings at once what this
comes so that it's Council that has to
approve the treasury management strategy
and it's up to this committee to decide
whether to recommend the strategy as it
stands or with any amendments to fall
council so that in principle the
authority to lend to other local
councils will be set out in the strategy
in terms of how that individual decision
was made on a daily basis that would be
an office so if it was agreed that we
would have the facility to lend to local
authorities in terms of individual
investment decisions that would be an
officer decision in line with our
treasury management policies and
procedures so we agreed the policy and
then the officers are then have the
ability to make those decisions
yeah under the section one fat ones
delegated authority the officers have
the ability as they do now to make the
investment decisions on their you know
the daily deals that they have to do
okay
nobody has indicated to us can you
further questions my directly okay I've
wanted to attend another substantive
element of the current review I wanted
to turn to page 8 point 7 in particular
to paragraph 6 point 1 and table
just like some clarification as to what
expecting the investments mean rising
from three million pounds to 6.6 million
pounds over something like four to five
years
so these are the expected level of
investment at the end of each one of
those financial years so we're expecting
given our current predicted income
streams over those five years this is
where we expect investments to be at the
end of those five meters do you mean
reserves I mean I mean it will tie in
with results they all mean cash out on
deposit as investment so you expect the
council to spend much less than its
receivable or somehow get more than it
currently receives I expect that without
without major projects spend which isn't
built into this report because we're not
asking for any current majors project
spends at the moment I expect our level
of reserves to grow and that mirrors the
level of reserves because we're not
spending the money fascinating in that
case that's like the risk we've been
talking about an even greater
perspective now maybe that's what you
meant by increasing the diversity new
you may have been referring to that when
you said by limiting the categories you
can lend to would reduce the diversity
and therefore we'd have to lend to more
banks because you've got more money and
you'd be limited by the amount you could
place with them for how long is that
correct it's correct right
so that's highly speculative isn't it
that we'll end up with 6.6 million
pounds in 20 21 22 because as you say it
does
incorporate any consideration in future
projects okay we move to okay this one
was really really interesting because
when you get to the bottom of 9.5 take
you've turnovers 12 last sentence of 9.5
it says at the very end of all this it
is unlikely the council we're requiring
borrowing in advance of need I can't
really understand why that's at the end
and not at the beginning because of it
doesn't make any sense to me and then
when you read 9.2 you're talking about
all the section 1 5 1 officer will do in
terms of borrowing in advance and then
you immediately travel to 9.3 where it
talks about what the council is going to
do so I have a huge confusion as to why
9.2 talks about the section 1 5 1
officer and delegated powers to borrow
ahead of them in advance of Lee and then
in 9.3 in determining where the
borrowing will be undertaken advance of
the need the council will so is the
council gonna do it or the 1 5 1 office
are gonna do it I find this very
confusing and I don't think that that
whole section movie 9 right the way
through is actually telling me what we
need to be telling full councillor for
present time I think I see live exactly
shall I move up explain this
I mean if the strategy is clear that the
section one fire one officer has a
delegated power too far in advance of
need if it's about to being an
economically beneficial to the council I
agree maybe the wording can be slightly
clearer in nine point three and when we
make reference to the council it's still
go into the delegated authority of the
one by one offices I agree that wedding
using it only needs to say that so that
we know what we're saying so you're
taking him you know the sexual monk by
one or Kazu gonna take some real risks
there but why have we got at the end
it's unlikely the council will require
any borrowing in advance of me
that should be in the beginning so with
the section 1.1 office of reads it
they're thinking I should be doing this
the strategy is to set out our policy
and then we've also added some local
context and make that you know to put
the actual applicability of the policies
into context so what we're saying is
we've set out the policies that accounts
were to Tier two but then put some local
context about this time ethically it's
unlikely that we wouldn't want to take
off those delegations but I mean we
could change the order of it but it
wouldn't change this absolutely all is
important because whenever it came to
any debates wherever that might be as to
whether the intentions of the council
spin follows it would start with it's
unlikely the council will require any
borrowing in advance of need which puts
a greater onus on the section one five
line officer to really really really
think where there is necessary and
appropriate it needs to come first
as my adult training tells me that and
the clarification my every move too far
away
8:18 just approval ofc read these things
thirteen I come across something
completely new which I didn't know
anything about mithy - it was a tanker
that's a couple of we've talked about
nithy
- which I'm surprised that you haven't
spoken about this evening because you
know I've never seen before
and here we have a statement that myth 2
says all local authorities are to be
classified as retail counterparties and
we'll have to consider whether to opt
after professional status miss Authority
has met the criteria of opting after
professional status you namely continue
to invest in accordance with this
investment strategy I'd like to
understand that a bit more because hold
on if a local authority has done that
then how do we stand on the issues we've
just been discussing and what what does
professional status
what does it really confer on this
council and what would it take away from
the council that happens about that so
if we were to continue to be classified
as a retail and can't surpass you rather
than the professional body that would
severely injure on off flexibilities to
invest in the the kinds of investments
are on our lending list at the moment so
for example is money market funds we
wouldn't necessarily necessarily be able
to invest in those type of funds in
future and there's some specific
requirements around the sort of level of
balance insertion Authority has to hold
within this ten million and which need
to be taken into account
determining whether you can opt up to
the professional status or remain as a
retail counterparty I would again say
that the vast majority of local
authorities have chosen to opt up to
this professional status so we are in
line with what other local authorities
are doing and with this just allows us
to continue on our current investment
strategy so if we hadn't done this we
would basically have been quite a change
a departure from our current strategy in
terms of what we would have been able to
invest in did you say 10 million pounds
have we got 10 million barrels this
point isin average balance for 10
million pounds so as a as at the day we
opted out I see then you receive
everybody else's money that we give out
of the council tax is paid if that's
what you're saying
so we receive our own council tax we
receive council tax firm for Parris's we
receive the precepts for fought fire
aims for fire suffer in the year and and
the County Council then we've obviously
got a big pile of money so that big pile
of money counts towards this average of
10 noon yeah we basic clothes not our
money you know we basically had to prove
over an average of three depending on
which counter punk party wanted to look
at it we had to prove over a period of
time that we had an average balance of
ten million pounds that we had to opt
out that was one of the criteria another
criteria was that we had suitably
experienced off dealing and treasure
management how long is that ten million
pounds average to be required for well
that most two men she only asked for a
single day in a month but we proved over
a period of time that we're exceeding 10
million pounds
I laughed because I think that rather
strange thing professionally at least so
if a council hasn't opted for
professional status what does that imply
in terms of their participation in
borrowing from or lending to other local
authorities they can't so in terms of
the specifics I mention to local
authorities I don't think I'd have to
take that wage check because I don't
know it offensively offhand I don't
think there would be a specific impact
on the ability to lend to other local
authorities it was more around this
money market funds thing that I think
it'd be a good idea to check it can you
be good idea to champion I mean there is
a distinction between local authorities
and money market funds but we can check
on the specific around the lending to
local authorities if you're a retail no
Sherman is fine Thank You Keisha yes
I mean I do remember this was I think I
think we had yeah and I believe in part
of those discussions it was it was a
concern I think that to whether the this
local authority was large enough that it
might meet the criteria to to split it
to be classified under the professional
so you have found and managed to find a
way where this council has met that
criteria and he's is it something that
is reviewed on a annual basis every
three years or five years is it
something that the council might
potentially because it's bald and I
might not make the grade sometime in the
future so in terms of meeting the
criteria so we had various
counterparties would write to us for
example a bank or a bill that would
write to us and we've used previously
and they would have a various set of
questions that we would have to feeling
most of those so they say money market
funds when they write to us they would
ask have you hit ten million pounds in
the last three months our answer would
have been yes do you have suitably
trained staff that deal with rick
treasury management experience though
our office would be yesterday we fill in
those forms sending back and then that
notification whether we met their
criteria or not in all the circumstances
where we've been asked with many
criteria I have to go away and find out
when they would reassess if they would
reassess that criteria at any stage we
haven't spoke in detail with the link
about this education mentoring advisors
and Anna's name has said the mostly
local authorities a lot to offer
professional status more to give us
those options are out around continue to
lend me money market funds
as the report shows we can invest quite
a bit of money with money market funds
if we want a professional status that
would limit us to just invest in with
banks just just one question
it's quick if you don't go with that
professional status does that cut your
options yes - yes as I just said that we
would not you know if that was then
obviously we've gotta go with it - to
keep their options where they are we
already have to go on to professional
status so we're already on there if we
weren't there then the table that shows
get the page it's on page 8.15 you're
safe from that item that we can invest
with money market funds up to five
million pounds so we'd be looking to
have to face that five million pounds
within the banks using the credit
criteria mr. look up that table so our
limit will be a stage where we've been
leaving large sums of cash in our
current account a minimum five million
occasionally we yes we do maximize their
investment in mind okay yeah if you take
an average balance of ten million pound
we would put it five million in money
market fund right
but what looks taken indication it's a
recorded vote on the issue of continuing
to them to local authorities given the
concerns just some show
see that's just for the record if you're
talking about mr. chairman before we get
up for that option
I believe counsel mr. Mason I was
concerned about the presentation in 0.9
and I think we have asked or there was
is a request for that to be reworded to
better reflect the expectation and the
intention that has been firmly given to
us so I'm not sure that we can reword it
here we could but it would take time
because obviously it's confusing that we
need certainly the last thing at the
beginning and we need to know that it's
not the council it's a 1.10 pizza so can
we take that away to be rewritten or do
you want to correct it here I'm happy to
make the suggested changes to the
paragraph 9 in and if you'll be aware
that the papers before council which is
surveyed leads to have been published in
draft but we believe the pain
I don't know the exact procedures but we
need the table a revised version at the
meeting or just make reference to the
fact that it will be amended I am I
believe uh Sir John yes it's fine I mean
ordinarily you they'll be
recommendations from this commission and
and whether they're picked up by by by
the officer or all-comers of its report
from this committee either way about
that that will go into the 14th of
February council council consideration
actually hours a week are you somehow
advice to changes about fitting their
wording the most amazing model or about
the fronts and changing the reference to
the council in section one that one okay
I'm gonna say that council quite I'm
referring to a point to free where we've
got a recommendation and I see in 23.1
least seven items
most of those are announcing each
council Mason saw that there was an
addition in those recommendations or
holy Ben
yes I'm not sure to them and how do you
treat the it's up to you what thing
seems to be a separate decision because
if I could put a suggestion for words
and I know John's probably going to jump
in on me number one is where you're
gonna answer it just an extent because
it's to note the capital and traffic
management strategy study including the
investment instruments indicators limits
and delegations containment in the
report but is that investment
instruments as I understand it where
you're gonna want to drop possibly local
authorities so that your biggie that's
ninety we don't want to note it we want
to recommend you come down to seven we
recommend the contents of this report
for foreign counsel with the great
changes and with removal evolved yes
recommendation separately yeah when
there is noting yeah as always visits an
open happy to note for five I don't
we've said whatever you think 666 is
irrelevant really six isn't really a
recommendation we've we've
identifying issues and we've discussed
it yeah so are we happier between remove
recommendation six obviously I think
members are happy to note
recommendations two to five including
both you can take a vote on the issue of
recommending the contents of this report
to forecastle and then it's up to
members to signify whether they agree
with that with all they don't it's okay
so it's recommended that context the
report with the removal of optional
enter no I'm not making apologies vessel
I'm just saying five versus day but I
can't recommend the contents of this
report to the council no actually for
the reasons I'm I put I don't have to in
a minute you can you just repeat what
we're voting on potential options into
the recommendation we compare for it
okay
I'm really very reliable and very
flexible mentation is number seven with
number five from the potential options
and then we've got a positive
recommendation rather than negative
world are members clear on that is a
green recommendation number seven
including option okay yes okay yep
members in favor of that
this is what yeah yeah
and the names will actually be recorded
in the mini
somebody clearly the value of just gonna
take to premium right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how would you decide which I think the
key thing with there was lack the
villages Frank new beans exactly so we
were settin invoicing system place to
ensure that we could say yes if Anubis
gone out we have actually invoice it
correctly and so far there's only known
for a couple of
of data there that we seem to be you
know the invoices seem to be matching up
accordingly in conclusion the new system
reads sort of topics at that little
pulse because I didn't follow from the
last time I wasn't quite sure who was
invoicing at home on this fateful so
which is why I ask the question by the
obvious sir are we invoicing the
residence or build over are we being
invoice the invoice in the business was
something we always do
yeah so we're quite clear to custom
services you know an order a new
business not going to be fun so unless
there is someone establishing that
painlessly makes those beans then the
bins doctor hell this is the invoices
that setback from Sue's so it's always
saying previously we had a system where
we provided all the stop and therefore
it's very hard to separate what stock
had been used for new beans or two new
properties or replacement means to
existing properties we didn't separate
the two hours we can do now to give them
and that's the 90 but how it done this
is basically said you have got to
provide the stock and in doing so we've
agreed that they invoices for the new
properties it's all reassuring is that
basic things hanging up so what they're
delivering ounce tallies up before that
she orders in so they do so if I can
just come back on that because and then
last year if you remember we only charge
for eight bins we do this and you
remember I had an email from you saying
that the home row developer had refused
to pay yes for the beans so obviously
they're therefore if we're supplying
them that they're because our policy is
that
they should be paid for so these are bit
the ones in Hall Road or any other is
like are being paid for by the residents
if not by the defendant correct yes
they're all pea and some Hall Road had
had a change of heart as well so it's
actually split into two well that's one
no there's two separate companies so
abstract its own so that one one side
the Kings side had a change of heart so
that so the other side may follow suit
but equally what we're doing interesting
means Tommy so nobody expects the
resident who's into two pie it's like
that we found that to be compliant and
we're getting running in advance so that
we don't end up with debts of choice we
always ensure you have a money advance
before sending them okay thank you
associations as well
yes so I again it's exactly the same
sort of thing that didn't leave my
understanding of that and many of those
are flats and some slightly more items
at 1100 beans that kind of thing but
again yes they did contribute to that in
the stands
counselor mr. Mason Thank You Gemma now
how do you monitor your staff control
because just before Christmas I was
receiving complaints yes mum just felt
like they just
that people had damaged green bins we
weren't able to get the Green Team
correct because somehow we didn't have
any and the other side of the coin is
okay that's a situation where we we are
replacing all really painful damaged
bins and of course we need to make sure
we've got to stop for the people whose
houses are new so how are we doing what
we do now it's a good question actually
you know possibly on the motor on Stan a
few months ago it is a problem that the
Rose's head and what we are semantically
are what we please summary of the
existing stock that we have from Suez
and we also track the deliveries inand
always they have so as soon as we're
establishing baseline levels of what we
think and except for lovers of stock so
if we say if it goes blow that whistle
hits amber we're saying please tell us
you've placed an order and they go yes
we can confirm there we go thank you
very much of course they haven't once a
week why to replace one tomorrow very
quickly so we aren't we are monitoring
something but they take the subjects we
spot check those spot checks if you like
that that makes sense to ensure there's
some additional compliance but wait wait
we now have a summary of number of leads
number of being carcasses that kind of
thing so that shouldn't happen in the
future okay I've got a splitting
migraine but every Friday we vote you
brought that in okay
you're asking should be irrational thank
you
Thank You counselor Stan Thank You
chairman is it does the council supply
those bins that we've got open tops to
them or are they all closed off and all
the residents over to replace any part
of the being in other words ruins and
tops and that's all baby if they've got
damaged or missing or we were missing up
you can get me bring up and they should
come out in the place there's a stock of
those I can have a level of hairy wheels
and no question so the recommendation is
that PC zones no charging system
[Applause]
[Music]
green baize number 13 17 brain field
register decision was made on the 30th
of January 1517 draft housing allocation
policy approval complication the report
was published on the 2nd of February
16:17 private sector housing policy that
was already on there and it was
postponed from January now will be made
this month
17:17 memorandum of understanding the
Essex recreation disturbance avoidance
of the litigation strategy decision
we've made on the 30th of January number
1817 bond receptor chronic medication
that was already on there for the last
month and we believe the group will be
meeting sometime this month to make
those allocations and then finally be
only new one number 119 removal of
credit debit card payment for car parks
note says that the software is outdated
oh yeah people pay by phone and I
understand it though you feel please can
use yeah
discography
especially white and captain Marcus here
there's not supported on a mic breather
support with on every phone in 1629
contemporary will you stop that followed
by I think it's actually down to the
cost and how much the software changes
should cost me one Rico which is the
reason why I make more money I'm sorry I
mustn't get back on that but my taking
obviously cancer Spanish oh oh thanks
shimming are are we signed up with the
people to park in the car park we'll
have to phone out the parking people
because they they would live there
communicator doesn't work right so that
parking system that they've got in your
cup in the cat's car park where you
found out the bullet to get us although
able to pay cash they'll have to use the
other forms of payment I mean if you
want more information in the world
markers to come until next month to talk
about it I think it was around there did
you ask him to give us a route though
whether it be a report that's defaulting
yeah but he won't if I'm perhaps I can
you see the report and in the decision
will be made
you could come with that any fortune
just ask the questions yet or you could
just contact mark this thing he will be
probably brining it about now so if you
want to get your into it okay we got
that much to say on that one of coming
up to me a bit of range a range of
pre-meeting so those members on that
group we could respond to late
as soon as possible and the ICT review
is taking place next week yes okay